Je te vois épouser un cadavre vivant dans une
tombe que l'Empire peut prendre de très nombreuses
formes différentes ce projet de loi parfois il
apparaît comme un pari et parfois il y a un
petit nuage de vapeur tourbillonnant de cette
façon il peut se déplacer sans être vu parmi ses ennemis
fils de Dracula partageant le  écran avec une
nouvelle terreur dans cette histoire étrange des
morts-vivants qui sortent de la tombe la
nuit pour s'attaquer à des victimes sans méfiance
avec Louise al Britton Robert Paige
Evelyn pétroliers Frank Craven J Edward
Bromberg et lon Cheney en tant que MU Count
Dracula vous frissonnez devant les écrans
femme la plus fascinante vampire attirant les hommes
avec une beauté froide et la promesse de l'
immortalité le comte Alucard est immortel à
travers lui j'ai atteint l'immortalité à
travers moi tu feras la même chose
toi